Well, unless Grant plans on paying other
people to buy his products, he'll
presumably bring in some money each time
he sells a nozzle, and each time he sells
a set of wipers. This means that the money
he earns is going to be equal to the money
he makes from his wiper sales plus the
money he makes from the nozzle sales,
which is just this first choice up here.
For example, let's say, just picking
numbers out of the air, that Grant decides
to sell a wiper set for $5 and one nozzle
for $3. Well, then we know that money
earned at that point would be equal to $5
plus $3 or let's see, if I was going to
pay for these, it would be 5, 6, 7, $8
total. So all we would do to find the
total money earned would be to add the
cost of each of the products together.